[Music]
dr norton i want to walk you through the
last decade of my life okay i even wrote
some of this down to make sure i get it
so
10 to 15 years ago i'm still exercising
like the high school wanna be
like college wannabe athlete that i
thought i still was
every year i was getting a little bit
bigger and a little bit bigger a little
bit bigger and then atia hits the scene
and he's he's somebody i have high
respect for brilliant brilliant guy
his the first guy said maybe we need to
look at this differently mechanistically
then i got into gary tobbs and then then
i somehow landed to aspiri
and then everything was about
bulletproof and mainline stuff right and
so then i'm i'm i would cook bacon i
would eat it and then i would take the
bacon grease and dump it into my coffee
and i was a mainline it was it was it
was disgusting but here's what happened
i lost a lot of weight
and what i came to realize over time is
um
i would start eating at about four
o'clock in the afternoon
and what you talked about earlier was at
the beginning i was probably having
seven or eight thousand calories a day
by the time i'd been doing this for 90
days a i looked like emaciated and like
i had been left on a desert island for a
while but but
i was my
my caloric intake was so low right i was
i was eating that much but then i moved
over to you know baylor and the calorie
myth and then i got my own glucose
monitor and just started following all
these fad diets
man here's all the stuff my wife used to
say before we would uh
at the beginning of every month before
she go to the grocery store she would
just be like john what are we this month
are we like raw vegan like what are we
doing she was such a trooper
um high fat vegan no carb no sugar i've
done it all all of them um low grain
all of it
every nothing is more of a third rail
like i could me and you could sit here
and talk about religious rights and
abortion rights and we get less drama
than when you tell somebody don't drink
diet coke or you should drink diet coke
right so probably true
what are what what are we supposed to do
because i know how to read studies and
it's a pain in the butt and it takes a
long time and it's easier just to scroll
through instagram you know how to read
studies we do this for a living and it
still gets cumbersome
what is the average mom just the dad
who's just 32 and he's got two young
kids and he's starting to notice like
man it's hard for me to bend over now
is there a way to paint with a broad
brush
what people should broadly be doing when
it comes to eating and then we'll get to
exercise here in a minute i feel like
it's just chaos man yeah
so
there's actually a lot that you just
brought up there that's great to go over
so the first thing is
people make the wrong associations and
it's
just because something worked
it's important to understand why it
worked
right so we don't make the wrong
association so let's take intermittent
fasting for example which sounds like
something you did um
people will lose weight on intermittent
fasting and they'll say something like
well see it's cause it's because i was
in fat burning mode in autophagy and my
insulin was low
and it's like
no dude you didn't eat for 20 hours and
you fit it all into a four-hour window
and like yeah you lost weight right but
that's that is not sexy that's not what
sells people on it because it just
sounds like oh well they're just saying
i eat i ate less right and again it
sounds a lot like disordered eating
right so right yeah you just drive
yourself congratulations
and you just brought up something which
is you slowly got heavier right like you
lose some weight regain it lose some
weight regain it but over time you were
getting heavier that's right
okay then the next question is all right
well maybe some diets are easier to
adhere to right compliance is the
science
and i really get into it like this is
it's like the messaging
behind what dave says with paying off
debt right yeah so people say well you
should pay off the the low the highest
interest rate first that just makes
sense because of math
it's like well if we were doing math we
wouldn't be in this problem in the first
place
right
that's right because this isn't this
isn't an x is an
it's not o's
knowledge issue this is this is a habits
and behaviors problem is what it is
so
when we look at there was actually two
meta-analyses done looking at various
different popular diets and seeing
okay did any of them perform better in
terms of fat loss
also were any of them easier to adhere
to and the research showed that none of
them really stood out performing better
in fat loss
and none of them appeared easier to
adhere to because
adherence appears to be a very
individual thing what's easy for one
person
may be very difficult for another and
vice versa and i think this is why we
have like again so much difficulty
because what will often happen and i'm
guilty of this
so i follow something called flexible
dieting which basically i have my
protein carbs and fats
um the targets for the day and calories
and i just focus on hitting those and i
i try to use you know quote-unquote good
foods to hit those but for the most part
i'm just like let's just be consistent
with this right
let's make sure we're picking up the big
rocks
and
like i thought because
that felt easy to me because previously
i was trying to quote unquote eat clean
and here's what would happen i'd eat
clean all week this is in college i eat
clean all week my buddies would order
pizza on the week weekend and i would
eat like a whole large pizza right
and it's like hey do you do it's like a
budget right so
like if you are great saving throughout
the week but then you go you know you
know popping bottles at the club on the
weekend
guess what happens to your weekly budget
it gets blown yeah right right
budget still counts on the weekends and
guess what kitties calories still count
on the weekend
so i kind of was like well instead of
like going ham because i feel so
deprived what if i just allowed myself
to eat this stuff in moderation and just
you know just tracked it right
so i started doing that
and lo and behold it worked right in
fact i even did a i joke i did an entire
contest prep
and i had
at least one ice cream sandwich a day
now i'm not saying you've got it it's
the greatest prep ever
well here's the thing though
because that stuff even though it's
tasty
you're getting pretty small
like intake for quite a bit of calories
yeah so i would by default as i'm
getting leaner and leaner my calories
are getting lower and lower
i'm going to have to adjust the foods
that i eat
to accommodate for that otherwise i'm
going to be really hungry so again a
budget example is great right
so if you make
a million bucks a year
right
if you
uh can pay your mortgage and you can
pay your utilities and all your
responsibilities and
you set money aside for all the stuff
you need to and then you want to buy
yourself a real awesome sports car for
200 000
is that okay to do
maybe
right if you can meet all those other
obligations right but should you do that
if it's going to make you go broke if
you have a small budget right of course
not yeah right
um well this calorie is the same thing
if you're an athlete who's you know
expending four or five thousand calories
a day
hey if you want to have a slice of
cheesecake or something like that it's
not going to hurt you because like it's
just getting churned up in your daily
burn i remember that remember that photo
of michael phelps his diet yeah that
gave me so much i was like oh man i play
uh ymca basketball i can eat uh
seven big macs then you know i mean dude
it kicked that killed me but you're
right he was burning up 25 000 calories
a day
right so oh man um it changes
what you do based on that but really
what most people need to do is get
consistent
you just use two words that i hate
intentional and consistent
i need something better than that i need
a bad guy and
a special
intolerance and i need some genetic
information i need that the best diet
for you
is probably the one
that you can stick to
in the long term
and be adherent to and that is going to
be different from individual to
individual and probably the one that
feels
so in order to lose weight
you must practice some form of
restriction whether it's counting
calories low carb etc etc
but you can pick the form of restriction
that feels least restrictive to you
and that's probably what you should do
because it's going to feel the least
taxing over time
because consistency is the name of the
game and so just i want to interrupt
just just so the listener knows
in my house
i eat a
generally low carb no sugar diet unless
i am mainlining ice cream and gummy
candies which happens
um
but
my wife doesn't she has
many more carbs than i do uh and i'm not
talking i'm talking about grains and
sugars not not salads and things
and so it's as simple as when she makes
dinner she will
make part of the dish without the rice
in it or she'll make part of the dish
without the tortillas in it or whatever
and we've been doing that for a decade
now we've both landed on and i hear
houses divided that's just people not
being intentional not caring about each
other it's not hard um it takes an extra
three seconds to not put a tortilla on
something or to put but it's a matter of
what you just said here's what works for
us most of the time and i can always
look back when i look and be like i just
found 15 extra pounds i didn't notice
and i fluctuate a lot i drop water
pretty quick and put it back on pretty
quick it always comes back to what you
just said consistency and intentionality